tony wilson we played four hours of
Metro Exodus the other day on Xbox one I
want to talk to you about how risky this
game is as far as developer forays
involvement goes and making this game
and kind of evolving this as the third
game in a trilogy the first two games
very underrated last night's one of my
personal favorites but they've done a
lot of different things with this game
it's not open-world per se and they're
stressing that to metro fans but we
played for hours and we were in this one
open-world sandbox what was that like so
we've been using the term around the
office semi open-world a lot and I think
that's a good way to describe it
examples of that would be like God of
War from last year where you kind of
have these larger biomes that you're
going through tomb Raider's very similar
to that - where yes this is a big map
but you're going through multiple big
maps throughout the game you're not just
going through directed levels you don't
have one giant world you're exploring
the whole time but you have essentially
large chapters of a map it's still that
story like Artyom you're playing him
again and Miller and friends are going
across the post-nuclear Russia on a
train there's only four seasons that
kind of runs me the last of us we were
playing like the desert area we spent
four hours and apparently I only
completed like half of what I could have
there so they were saying size-wise and
I can't stress enough how big this is
it's obviously not like open-world
breath of a while big but for a metro
game I don't think people understand how
big it is we I like I trekked maybe for
20 minutes and I was like that must have
been most the map and I looked at my map
and I saw like where I came from and
where I ended up as a holy [ __ ] that was
only like probably a tenth of the map
they've got vehicles this time and even
with a vehicle it's gonna take you a
long time to get from point A to point B
and the vehicles like obviously there
were vehicles before but they were all
on Rails being Metro but this we had
like a van this rickety van with I love
how there's like no suspension in it it
was very slap slipshod and everything
and put together not even like a real
ignition key you just you literally get
the door handle that you insert to get
inside I want to talk about the how it
works have a loop of that scavenging
combat stealth quests works I spend most
of my time scavenging and like the
people there from Deep Silver were like
make sure you're always scavenging and
it's not a problem for me because it
games like fallout or earlier metro
games I'm one of those person who hoards
every possible bullet and bullets were
even literally a currency in the first
two Metro games but it took me a while
because this game can be difficult I ran
out of ammo for both of my main weapons
had to switch to my sniper rifle in
close quarters until I could get to a
workbench and like you said you didn't
get one till one like an hour in yeah
it's probably an hour and before I got
the opportunity to actually Forge any
ammo for myself because I did run out as
well so that sort of survival aspect of
making every bullet count is still very
much here even with bullets not being
currency it seems in this game with them
being strictly ammo
you're still gonna run out and you're
still going to be you know saving that
last shot hoping that you're able to
down one of these new humanimal 'he's in
time
[Applause]
as far as the quest structure goes you
come into the caspian desert it used to
be the Caspian Sea you know it's largely
dried up you come into the desert and
you see this van following you and you
kind of see a couple bandits in it so
your overall objective at the beginning
is Miller tells you to go investigate
what the hell are they doing here also
you need like water for the crew because
you're very short on supplies so oh
there's a village we'll go get water
from there you meet someone and you have
a choice to kill or spare him and we'll
talk about that in a bit
but did you like how it kind of gave you
quest it's pretty traditional as far as
open world quests acquisition goes yeah
I was sort of meet one of your fellow
train travelers get some new objectives
I think it led to some interesting set
pieces right like you meet Anna I
believe was her name and she tells you
hey there's a sniper over on this tower
you can check out there's a slave ship
then you can explore despite it being an
open world for you to explore of
whatever scale it is you still have
these sort of set pieces and more
directed experiences along the way and
even the main mission we were doing took
us down into like this archives kind of
area and that felt very akin to one of
the first two games where it's a much
more driven experience much more of a
level to use that term as opposed to
little spiders where there you have to
shine your flashlight on to flip them
over and everything yeah there's
claustrophobic yeah you have like a
crawling through the vents moment where
you're you know you got to turn off your
flashlight to reload so you hope you're
not getting swarmed during those couple
seconds
yeah and it works out very well because
it feels like Metro in those instances
but it feels like you're going between
different Metro like you said set pieces
it feels almost like there are these
bite-sized levels that you're going
between that crane there's a sniper up
there you can go to this like radio
tower and like you get like tangible
rewards for doing all these you get new
weapon attachments that you can craft
different like scopes with and
everything but like by and large
developer for aides been telling metro
fans don't worry it's still a metro game
to me it did feel like a metro game so I
spared this first bandit and then later
on I went to sleep because you can rest
to change to night or day and like
shadows and the stealth are very much
still Metro if you're in the shadows
you're harder to see obviously and you
can shoot out light bulbs but I was
going to approach that sniper so I'm
like I'll rest make it night and I woke
up and the guy who had spared was
staring right at me with his gang he's
like don't worry if I would have wanted
to kill you I would have already turns
out he was trying to organize a coup to
become the bandit leader so he
propositioned me to go kill the current
leader and I thought that was pretty
cool I mean the games been doing that
for a while now the choice of sparing
him led to this quest
I pulled my gun out on accident so he
left me a gun as like kind of a bribe so
I picked it up and I was like a me at
him on accident and the whole gang
pulled their guns like what were you
doing we're just talking I put my gun
away like that's that's better and that
was cool but it like broke my quest and
I want to talk about the drank because
people have come to expect some rough
edges and Metro games redux was a little
better but especially the original
version of 2033 this game still in my
experience had a lot of problems
technically it's it's important to note
we were playing on a xbox one dev kit
and this was not the final build they
stressed that to us that'll be out on
February 15 obviously but this build we
played it had a few problems I got stuck
in a few staircase and I had to reload
previous saves it broke that quest
because once I did pull out my gun
despite the fact we went back to be
peaceful I couldn't get him to give me
the quest again and my last checkpoint
was after I had woken up so I couldn't
complete that quest as cool as it was
and I came across it I didn't have to do
any reloads fortunately most of what I
encountered this like the typical
ragdoll jank of like oh this this
soldier or whatever is dead and now his
body's kind of spasming in a weird way
so I didn't encounter any like to use
the term like Fallout 76 level of Jan
you know nothing broke the game for me
fortunately and that's good and I hope
that of those like quest breaking things
those do get ironed out the game is only
a month away and maybe like the actual
physical digital release won't have that
problem but the dev kit we played had
that quest problem which is a bummer
because that was a cool point in the
game or you know Joe how my choice
mattered a little bit other games do
that but it was nice to see that in this
Metro game overall do the risks that
developer for a are taking seem like
they're headed in the right direction I
think so because despite this being sort
of the semi open-world kind of design as
we said before you still have these set
pieces and like directed experiences so
if you still want basically a standard
level you still have those there the
difference is there now just houses
within a larger world that you can also
explore when you're not doing the main
objective to find some other cool
yeah so Metro Exodus releases in about a
month exactly from today it's gonna be
February 15 for Xbox one ps4 and PC but
make sure to read our written preview we
will have that up from one of our
editorial and folks over in the UK and
we'll have other news about Metro Exodus
coming out in the next month so stick
around we'll see you